this is here to give us a talk Gatos is
with deep data intelligence I don't know
what that is he'll tell us and please
welcome Gatos so in 1431 a merchant by
the name of John beer was traveling from
Hampshire to London on his cart
John had one pound of cheese and one
quarter of quicklime a quarter being a
unit volley a unit volume in that time
on market day he sets up his store and
puts his goods on for sale the first
customer arrives and inquires about the
cheese the customer says I would like
one pound
the customer says I require I would like
one pound of cheese and John beer was
like off excitedly I might have a sale
and John the customers how much how much
does it cost John says ah for one he had
bought one one pound of cheese in
Hampshire 15 pence he he says one pound
of cheese in London is ten pence I said
then the the customer is like it's a
very good teeth deal cheese in Hampshire
is very good I would love to have some
cheese for my dinner and for breakfast
tomorrow
so they exchanged the goods and
exchanged the money and both John and
the customer are happy with the
transaction after a while a builder
comes and inquires about some quick line
quick line being used in building or
construction and John had bought one
quarter which is a unit volume in
Hampshire for ninety pants and he says
to the customer it costs for one quarter
in London it costs fifteen pets and then
the customer thinks oh yes I can really
build this is good quick brown Hampshire
make some good quicklime I can really
build my home with this quicklime or
whether whatever they use it for so
again this exchanged the goods for money
and both John and the customer are happy
with the transaction so my question for
the audience is why were both John and
the customer happy with the transaction
all xima hands up Oh John's a good
businessman John he's a very good he's a
good different units so in 1431 in
Hampshire a pound was not the same as a
pound in London that's this tell you how
he's leading to data and pie database
it's it's very applicable it's very
applicable same thing with a quarter a
quarter was a standard measure back
there but it wasn't the same in all
these different regions around Britain
in fact the word for pound comes from
the word pondus I guess you want to know
so what did John beer have to do to sell
his product in 1431 he had to find in
Hampshire he had to find what the
measurement system was in that place
what the quality of the goods were what
find out the vendors what good vendors
are there might be a multiple vendors
what the price of those goods were in
the local currency yet to know the
language the dialect in Hampshire maybe
have certain words that use for certain
areas or some technicalities or what the
currencies are different currencies have
were also a problem in 1431 you have
lots of different privacy currencies in
Britain what what kind of storage was he
going to have before he shipped off his
goods at the source what were the raw
laws and religious customs of that area
then on the transportation what roads
was he gonna use was gonna use roads
when he good was he gonna go by ship to
London what kind of security did he need
to have to transport his goods from
Hampshire to London did he have to pay a
convoy of security was gonna go on a
group of merchants that go together
which is what they did in 1430 well
what was what packaging was he going to
use the transport his goods
finally the destination where he had to
do a lot the same things in London what
what was the mentorship minute
measurement system what was the quality
was the price language dialect
currencies were there any levies what
was a storage how is he gonna store it
what are the laws or religious customs
of 1431 and that you'd have to agree is
a massive job just to sell a bit of
cheese and a bit of quick loan a massive
job so what's the what's the answer to
John's problem standardization the
problem is Hampshire and London or don't
have the same standards John had to
understand the price of the goods in his
destination before even buying the goods
yet to have this whole planned out all
of it planned out and the travel
transport of information back in that
time was very slow it's a risky venture
for John to take the cheese and a quick
line to London so what he can't really
do is by the way here he can't really
scale it's very hard for him to add
another product what they scale he also
said it's a bit cheesy this so I've lost
my train of thought thank you yes so
it's very hard to add a new product our
product we'd have to go through this
process again and keep on monitoring the
process I see transport is good for me
to be and what they tended to do back
then is go to get in print increased
profits was to go into quality because a
showing quality for one good was much
easier than to scale our horizontally
standardization so the first so I've
I've done the research here so all of
these these are actual records that I
found I feel that finding understanding
history is a good indicator for knowing
what to do because many of these
problems have been solved in the past so
in 1959 there's an audience by King
Edgar
which was
the standardization of money in
different air areas and what he tried to
do you're someone successful in 1215 the
magna carta try to standardize weights
and I think it was length the biggest
change happened in 1824 with a weights
and measures act however I would like to
read out the top one for you in 1924 it
is quite late so there are still in use
25 local corn weights and measures 12
different bushels 13 different pounds 10
different stone and nine different
tongues in 1924 this is after the first
world war which is how the hell did they
conduct a war like how did the
quartermaster say I need this from you
and he that from you must have been a
mental undertaking but I just read out
another part why was this the case
examination on arson right when
confronted by local customs so strong
that many have survived to the present
day so the problem is not a
technological one the problem is a human
one how can how can you convince these
people that this that you should
standardize the way that you transport
goods and that you have the same
language throughout that process so so
this is very similar to a data engineers
problem or the problem that you face you
when you get data you get them in many
different from many different sources
databases FTP API s3 facets HTML you
might do web spec all these areas to get
your data they come in many different
formats you got JSON XML CSV arcane or
some weird format that somebody on some
vendor create just put in their LinkedIn
for file and then you have to work with
and spend weeks trying to decipher
understand what what actually he
intended to do then it could be many
different compression formats zip zip
tar.gz
gzip etc etc zip and tar.gz a awful
formats in my opinion well we can talk
about that later
don't ever do it I'll just think please
don't let me do it and then what you
really have is you can have all these
different four sources with all these
different formats with all these
different compression types and its
really a cross drawing problem on what
you really want is to get your data into
the data warehouse in a two dimensional
format on the left you have multi
multi-dimensional data on the right you
have two dimensions this is where your
stakeholders are consuming your data and
see more complicated it's not just a
relational database we have an you can
have an intercom stores you have schema
on read which ones do you use how can I
make a simple enough process that is
maintainable enough for me to have a
data warehouse which you can have a
large variety of data a data warehouse
as to things which at least two things
that make it work well one it has to
have a large variety of data the data
warehouse is the modern paradigm of a
library if a library only has one topic
not many people are gonna go to that
library and read its books the second
thing it has to be trusted source of
information if I'm not getting my data
when I expect it to be there that I'm
not really gonna use that for my systems
that I produce later on so how do i what
kind of way can I do this so I don't
have to code it all the same way every
or have to code it in different ways for
every single one of my pipelines so the
only bit of Python I actually have in
this talk is that anybody know where
that's from yeah it's a bit more
complicated and simple but I'll get
we'll get into it so let's start off
what we have to do we have our source
data and this is our data infrastructure
where we'll be doing our work and we
have a data warehouse which is typically
the place where people consume their
data right it's like the sequel queries
join different data sets to getting a
bit literal you have your data Lake who
here knows where the data Lake is or has
used the data like show of hands please
who hasn't
question okay Oh fifty-fifty okay so a
quick introduction to data Lakes
a data Lake is imagine on your computer
your files and folders wait and save
your data a data Lake is something on
the cloud where you can anybody that you
allow can have access to that data it's
one central place whereas if it's on a
server the server might go down the
server
you can't request it with API
transactions but you can on a data Lake
and it's meant to be scaled out and can
have a lot of data on there some typical
examples are Amazon Web Services s3
there's digital ocean spaces there's I
think it's Google Storage some other
ones cloud storage okay so then let's
look at the top we have a compute layer
and a storage later right this is how
we're gonna work through it the first
process is you want to extract your data
now this by far please if you're gonna
remember anything please remember this
bit right there when you extract your
data save your data in its raw form
somewhere in your data Lake it can be in
your folder file system but save it in
its raw form that means if you get a
HTML website your web if you're scraping
a website you should save that website
in its raw HTML form to get it later why
is that important so if I'm web scraping
something and let's say my my so
typically what people do they extract
the data they or they they scrape it on
the fly from the live web site and then
put it into the database but let's say
that process is broken and I'd scraped
something that's not actually correct if
I don't have the actual saving extracted
file I can never go backwards in time
that data is always lost I'll never have
it again so you should be saving your
data as soon as you get it the next
process is a transform and Loewe process
this is very simple as it goes over the
cogs here are compute and the lower
level is the storage yeah so which is
where you take your data and you
transform it and load it on the fly
right into your data warehouse to be
consumed and that is a very good
pipeline it has very few nodes the data
is going from left to right that's it's
pretty good however
sometimes what happens is you might need
to transform your data and save it as
files again right so this is where you
have another transform phase and after
that you load that into your data set
however this is not as good as the first
method because let's say that I have a
problem in my data I'm looking at the
main table I'm querying it and I see are
these rows really weird now why is it
weird you have to try and investigate
back into those previous nodes where
that raw original format is so if I have
a transform layer well that's not the
original source of the data I might have
to go back to the extracted layer having
like like this is much easier to find
where the original problem was does that
make sense so far just a nonce yeah okay
so that's a good framework however
you're not you don't have you're not
sure whether you're the data you're
getting is correct or not something
throughout your process could be
incorrect and the data that you can
stakeholder is getting is wrong it's
very important that your stakeholder
gets the right data if I'm buying a
product of the supermarket I shouldn't
have to look inside the product to see
what what it is in there
I should have the the confidence of
knowing that the data I'm querying is
fine I shouldn't have to valid the
end-user shouldn't have to validate that
data so we add a validation stage of the
extract phase so let's say I'm calling
an API and after let's do a web scraper
I'm scraping a website I expect on that
website to have these fields but this
data exists that table would exist in
that HTML website if it doesn't then
save that data into an extracted failed
area so you can have a look at what the
problem was and change your or your
functional methodology to understand how
things have changed throughout the
process next thing what you should do is
validate your data before it's given to
your stakeholder or before you consume
it won't for whatever reason have a
validation put your data into a staging
table then have a validation function or
validation sequel query that you run on
your data that says ah is this data like
the one I
affect it to be so there's two real
areas I've seen where you can validate
you can validate on their on like none
like that is the schema correct this
schema on read or we can validate on the
business logic that happens in that data
that you get so for example I should be
expecting these three values in my data
are make sure that that data is in there
know if it's no then you fail it if it's
yes then it carries on and then you need
monitoring and all these different
processes just say where where is it
breaking where is it working and that
should always you should always be
informed in that in fact what you should
be doing is you should have a this goes
more into data as a product the final
consumer should be able to see the
monitoring that happens when your data
when they can fumarole your data they
should be like oh this this has been
reliable for a year two years nothing is
broken your managers should be able to
see that your processes are working well
and you should be able to see that your
processes processes are working well and
where they fail if they do if they fail
it's not your fault it's not always your
fault now that the data is dirty and you
have to think of a good process to clean
that data and when it failed you go back
to it and you clean it you understand
what the problems are so as a result of
this you have two situations as time
goes on this is what you like to do you
like your data to be trickling into your
your database but let's say that we have
a validation fail in this area those two
situations can happen
we can either so we get our data we stop
it and no more data goes in or it failed
some number of processes but we get
snippets of that data in which one do we
use do we use the but the middle one or
the bottom one
is the middle anybody wanna elaborate
why middle or why the bottom please
possible but you could you could find
out with a validation sequel pretty or
yes you end consumers correct they won't
know where the holes are they'll assume
that the whole data is fine but actual
fact you can either either it's just the
stakeholder should be aware of which one
you're using when you publish that data
if they're if they're happy with writing
their sequel queries that they could be
gaps in that's fine but they should be
aware of that process in general yes the
middle one is what you should be aiming
for so what happens is and you go back
it's failed you check what the problem
is you fix the code you improve it and
then your data continues going forward
or you go down to each little gap and
you fill it in so let's go through some
principles of what I've described here
so far so the main important thing is
understanding your data consumer what
what by far what do they want do they
want streaming tough how quick do they
need their information and their
insights do they need it in seconds they
need it in hours do they need it in days
that will affect the signal you don't
use if you look at the diagram I haven't
put really any technology on there I've
just put cogs all right after an s3
bucket but you can use whatever you want
for that it has just been from
principles building that up right
understanding your data consumer and all
on your data will determine what you use
during in those toc processes keep your
data in its raw form I think we
understand why we don't want to lose any
of our data
don't delete or move or move your raw
data once it's landed that should be it
it should be very little time that you
go back and try to fix the problems in
your data your transformation of your
data should happen over all of time and
not just at the present moment you
should be able to go back throughout
your data and say like ah from five
years ago up to now my transformation
function extracts the data I want for my
extracted layer into my main table
perfectly well and that is the date
range aeneas problem really is to
maintain that transformations
you do not want to maintain other things
just that separate out your extract and
transform load process you don't want
one to fail in the other to continue or
you don't want that you want them to be
separate processes that happen by
themselves minimize the number of data
and compute nodes if I have too many
nodes in my system I have more chance
for bugs to crop up more error to happen
so by having only two I have a list of a
chance of anything actually had going
wrong that won't make your et ETL a
cyclical which means data should only
flow in one direction I've seen some
companies have databases which refer to
other databases and they cycle around
and it back to itself what is the true
source of your data anymore
if it could actually be lost you have no
idea evening databases how you structure
a database you should if you create a
new table it should be an a cyclical
nature it should only go in one
direction a validate your data before it
goes to its consumers joining should
happen at the database level in my p.m.
that's what sequel is made for your
pipeline should get the data in there if
you want to join it with something do it
on there and then monitor your data you
need to know how well it's working this
is very similar to what what - what John
had to do yet to understand the data
understand his product understand where
his destination and where I was going -
yeah under he didn't you shouldn't have
to delete or move his date or his
product too much around lots of
different areas he who was looking at he
was validating the data to make sure
that all that is adding his product to
make sure it was a good enough quality
to say to give to his final consumer he
was separating out his ETL so he was
buying the goods transporting them
cooking him somewhere else and he
probably had infrastructure in place for
all of those things
he was joining his data the database
level so that means that he was maybe
giving it to a wholesaler or supermarket
so I could be joining it with other
goods as well so final thing I want to
leave with you you should think the date
of data as a product just how you go
into a supermarket and you buy something
you should be able or even in library
you should be able to search for
something and find where that data is
without having having to investigate
that data and look inside that data for
what it actually has yes that's it
my company is deep data intelligence
we've got us online
what's my LinkedIn profile these are the
references I have used and found about
John Pierre who was actually a person in
1431
[Music]
[Applause]
so yeah thank you for that got his serve
no head very interesting talk so if the
requirement or the customer isn't sure
of what data they would need in the
first place is there any area of the
pipeline that we can work out anyways so
just I think sometimes we don't know
what the data what the requirement would
be is any other areas as I say without
having access to the data first in the
first time what are the what are the
things that we can do anyhow just
prepare for that okay I would say if the
customer doesn't know what data they
need before they consume it it's very
hard to know if I think of an analogy if
they walk into a supermarket and I don't
know what they're gonna buy how do you
think are they gonna find what it's
really the question that they have
there's if they have a think about what
question they're trying to solve and
then find the data from that question
that could solve that question for them
I mean you've got a large variety of
data sets that exist on the internet and
exist data vendors that can give you
their data and I think going to them and
understanding a bit more about what
they're trying to solve before looking
for the data there will be a better
option if that makes sense
any other questions
sorry if you read seeing like a state by
James D Scott which you may type may
have it goes into a lot of the
fascinating history of the fight to
impose standardized waste and measures
and it turned out that a lot of the
opposition to standardized weights and
measures was simply to avoid things like
uniform taxation across the country so
they're actually kind of arbitraging
and misreport and all that kind of thing
is there any parallel to that in I think
so yes like if you make a process easier
if you automate the process there'll be
less people doing jobs or be less jobs
for it they'll be less data engineer
engineers doing the work so yes the more
standardization frankly I had a very
good talk that said we should we this is
this is something that we shouldn't be
doing what we should be doing is going
to the moon frankly I feel like I'm a
postman for the Internet
I'm just getting data from one place to
another it should be such a trivial
thing like screw it I want to do more
interesting things than this right this
is this is to get an insight very
interesting talk
I was just wondering about all the
schema that you showed often I actually
find myself as a stakeholder because as
a data scientist we often are
stakeholders of those data because we
have to query them that I have to
investigate exactly this and do the
validation or suggest suggests the
validation and all you're spoken about
makes very sense my curious is all about
the very end when you talk about the
main data to the reading database do you
envisage at all
an additional validation stage where you
can check actually that what you query
that the query itself gives what you
would expect
so I normally when I'm making data
engineering products I do that at that
stage so I will make union of the two
data sets and compared that if I run a
query that gives me the same result as
you should be getting out at the end
so even for dinner and finally just a
joke do you have any recommendations for
English people in terms of adopted
European units of measurements next
question I wanted to ask about the
monitoring step yes so usually what
would you recommend as the best practice
to monitor after each and every step or
monitor at the end after everything is
done if you start from scratch
yeah airflow a good way to go onto your
data sets through that use Jenkins to do
it that's good
in my opinion you can't have monitoring
that so in Jenkins you can create
Jenkins files which have certain blocks
of code you can have any to tell you
where you go through those blocks when
it when the code fails and for what why
it fails if you're writing your code in
Python they have a lot of exceptions
create your own custom exceptions for
different problems I normally have for
example a validation function that will
spin off different custom exceptions
based on the problem that that happens
so you can find out what the problem is
much more easily than investigating what
the data issue is when in terms of
monitoring I would say airflow was a
good one
I hear there's not much documentation on
the airflow wonder what this but I just
wanted to like take a suggestion whether
say for example you are doing an extract
step so do you monitor that extract step
at that time of implementation only or
hold the once whole pipeline is
developed then you go to the monitoring
step you saying if you has an extra step
no I'm saying that say for example you
implement extract yeah step in the
pipeline yeah so do you
after implementing that step apply
monitoring or at the end of the whole
pipeline development right there this if
depends on the time constraints you
haven't building your code
you should build it throughout the
process of when you're writing
extraction functions in fact what you
should be doing is even standardizing
the way that you extract data so what I
do in my what I've taught my day to
endears and what I've implemented is
fold all these different databases I
have created Python code that extracts
data from databases FTP sites API s3 in
a standardized format you give it some
configuration and then it will spin out
the monitoring for you or the validation
stuff for you during that process so you
don't have to code it a thousand times
for the same thing
thank you
better if you go back to the process map
do you do most of the data cleaning and
by data cleaning I mean here like
requirements for data types in the
extract phase or in the transform and
load phase that depends on what your
data source is so if you're consuming
from a database and it's not my heart
it's hard to read a JDBC connection if
you're doing it from an API it's much
easier to do so you can't always do it
from all data sources but you should try
to do as much as possible in fact
databases are quite different data
source by themselves what you should be
hopefully doing is connecting straight
to the database and that's sort of your
problem
yeah sometimes you can't always validate
your data
[Applause]